REBECCA LAZIER: The
Journey to the West
is iconic landmark story
of Chinese culture.
And many of the students
in their applications
wrote, I grew up listening,
hearing these stories,
telling these stories.
I mean, these go back
to the Ming Dynasty.
Our production is
Fred's Act Four.
It's called Journey
Beyond the West.
The pilgrims, the
priest, and the ogre,
and the pig, and
the monkey king are
about to receive
these final scrolls.
And Fred inserts
that his home has
been destroyed by
the Jade Emperor.
And he has to go back
and avenge himself.
And it ends up being
an avenge story where
the monkey king is victorious.
And so this is completely
against any traditional telling
of the story.
So I think that's also very
exciting for the students.
SCOTT PARKER: We bring in
a lot of basic martial arts
that maybe anybody that's
done kung fu will know.
And then, as well
as that, we bring
it more contemporary to add some
movement and different things
that's new to everybody.
Even a well-seasoned martial
arts person or practitioner
will look at what we're
doing and be like, wow.
I've never seen anything
like that before.
NATHAN LAM: We drill
through basics.
And in wushu, basics
are always the hardest.
If you're 10 years old,
you're doing basics.
If you're 40 years old,
And Scott really interested in
how to drill that part into it.
It was amazing seeing other
people who haven't done wushu
before coming and really
take up the sport so quickly.
Because it's something
that's very, very hard,
and people usually start
at a really young age.
And they were able to just
pick it up and learn it.
REBECCA LAZIER: It's
the first time anything
like this has been done at
Princeton, both in terms
of inclusion of martial arts
within a choreographic setting
within the Lewis
Center for the Arts,
and then taking something that
is such a dynamic intersection
of many different cultures
and bringing it to life.
EDWARD LEUNG: I saw this on
the course list, and I thought,
this is a dream class for me.
I always want to do
wushu, but I never
had the opportunity to
explore it before college.
And I loved the cross-genre
aspect of this class
because it fuses music as well
as sociology, anthropology,
and wushu into
this 35-minute act.
SCOTT PARKER: To bring wushu
to people that have never
done it before, and to
see them get excited,
and to see them see these little
things that we do-- and I'm
showing them things.
And we go over and
go over and go over.
To see that, for me,
is the biggest joy.
And to be able to give that
now to students at Princeton
here with the Lewis Center
at the Atelier program
has really been, I mean,
just a dream come true.